bonsoir le chanteur algérien lounès
matoub a été assassiné aujourd'hui dans
son village de kabylie artiste engagé il
avait multiplié les prises de position
contre les islamistes
le génial avait d'ailleurs prise en
otage pendant quinze jours en 94 avant
de le relâcher
les autorités soupçonnent bien sûr les
intégristes mais l'assassinât n'a pas
été revendiquée pour le moment
stéphane du bas dans ses chansons les
intégristes étaient des monstres qui
éteignent les étoiles depuis très
longtemps
lounès matoub était menacée par le gia
qui ne supportaient pas ses chansons
vitriol ces textes ouvertement
contestataires il y a trois ans lounès
matoub se savait déjà en danger de mort
je sais peut-être que je fais pas je
vais faire partie du lot des prochaines
victimes
je vais mourir peut-être dans un mois ou
deux
madame je vais altman excusez moi mais
c'est qu'il faut que j'y retourne j'ai
mon combat à mener
il faut savoir distinguer entre la vie à
la mort les deux chandelles moi je
préfère mourir pour des idées tu de
mourir de lassitude ou de vieillesse
dans mon lit en 94
le génial avait enlevé le séquestrant
pendant deux semaines une fois libéré il
continue son combat en chansons pour la
laïcité et la cause berbère
sa musique était considérée comme
illicite par les islamistes qui
l'accusait de détourner les croyants du
courant
lounès matoub est le quatrième chanteur
algérien assassiné en quatre ans et à
l'instant le président chirac a dénoncé
le lâche assassinat de lounès matoub
nous y reviendrons plus longuement à
19h30